When I was a kid, I was 100% about astronauts, spaceships, sci-fi, and I was 0% pirates. The fact that pirates were badasses, that they didn't obey rules, that they were rebels, that did not speak to the little nerd boy that I was.
小时候，我百分之百是个宇航员、宇宙飞船和科幻迷，对海盗则是一点兴趣都没有。海盗那种硬汉形象、不守规矩、反叛的行为，对于当时的我那个小书呆子来说，完全没有任何吸引力。
But one of our producers, Elna Baker, she was into pirates. She liked how scary they were. And she told me this amazing story that has been her favorite since she first heard it. It's a true story about a man named Stede Bonnet.
但我们的制片人之一埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）对海盗很着迷。她喜欢那种令人恐惧的感觉，她告诉了我一个她第一次听到就一直铭记在心的精彩故事，这是一个关于斯蒂德·邦尼特（Stede Bonnet）的真实故事。
Who is known as the Gentleman Pirate. And basically, it takes place in the early 1700s. He was from Barbados, so he grew up on a plantation, a sugar plantation, to one of the wealthiest families in Barbados. He had 94 slaves. He was married, had three kids. And he traveled in high society, which is unusual for a pirate.
他被称为“绅士海盗”。故事发生在18世纪初，他来自巴巴多斯，在一个富有的甘蔗种植园家庭长大，是岛上最富有的人家之一。他拥有94名奴隶，有妻子和三个孩子，身处上流社会，这在海盗中并不多见。
Yeah. The vast majority of people who turned to piracy did so out of desperation, and this man didn't.
没错，绝大多数投身海盗事业的人都是因为绝望，而这个人并不是。
So who's this?
那么他是谁？
I've told this story so many times to so many people that I just wanted to make sure I was getting the facts right, so I decided to talk to a pirate historian. That's Mark Hanna. He's also a professor at UC San Diego.
我给太多人讲过这个故事了，我想确保事实准确，所以我决定找一位海盗历史学家聊聊。他就是马克·汉纳（Mark Hanna），也是加州大学圣地亚哥分校的教授。
The vast majority of pirates start their lives by mutinying, or they gather a crew together and they steal a ship from someone. He actually had a ship built. Thought, I will go down to the local shipyard. I'll have my ship built according to specifications that I think are best.
绝大多数海盗是通过兵变开始的，或者是召集一帮人去抢夺别人的船。而他竟然专门让人造了一艘船，他想：“我会去当地造船厂，按照我心目中最完美的规格造一艘船。”
And then he hired a crew and he paid them wages, like regular normal-people wages, which was a big no-no.
然后他雇了一群船员，给他们发工资，就像普通正常人那样发薪水，这在当时是大忌。
The vast majority of pirates, if you don't capture a ship, you don't make any money. You want your crew to be invested in the outcome of attacking a ship. So if you know, hey, I'm doing OK. I know I'll be paid this week, you're going to be a little less aggressive about capturing a ship. And so I think Bonnet, right off the bat, didn't understand the economic model that is the basis of most pirate attacks.
对绝大多数海盗来说，如果你不俘获船只，你就赚不到钱。你得让船员在袭击船只的结果中投入利益。如果你知道，“嘿，我过得还不错，我知道这周我能拿到工资，”那你对劫掠船只就不会那么积极了。所以我想邦尼特从一开始就不了解海盗袭击赖以生存的经济模式。
Then why did he want to be a pirate? What kind of midlife crisis is just like, I'm a wealthy landowner with a wife and three kids, and I'm going to just go marauding on the seven seas?
那他为什么要当海盗呢？什么样的中年危机才会让他觉得自己作为一个有妻有子、家境殷实的土地主，应该去七大洋上打家劫舍？
Well, it's explained in a book from 1724 this way.
好吧，1724年的一本书是这样解释的。
Captain Charles Johnson wrote, quote, "this humor of going a-pirating proceeded from a disorder in his mind which is said to have been occasioned by some discomforts he found in a married state."
查尔斯·约翰逊船长写道：“这种当海盗的冲动源于他内心的混乱，据说是由他在婚姻状态中感受到的一些不适引起的。”
Wait. What is he saying?
等等，他这话是什么意思？
He says-- and other books say the same thing-- that what led him to piracy was that he had a nagging wife.
他说——其他书上也这么说——导致他成为海盗的原因是他有一个爱唠叨的妻子。
No way.
不会吧。
Mhm.
嗯。
They're blaming the wife?
他们在责怪妻子？
They blame the nagging wife. So Bonnet has this ship built and he calls it The Revenge. And he makes sure that it has a cabin with a well-stocked library.
他们把责任推给了爱唠叨的妻子。于是邦尼特造了这艘船，取名为“复仇号”。他确保船舱里有一个存书丰富的图书馆。
Which doesn't seem that weird, if you're going to be on a boat for months at a time, that you have a lot of books.
如果你要在船上待上好几个月，带很多书似乎也没那么奇怪。
Most pirates are illiterate, Ira.
大多数海盗都是文盲，艾拉（Ira）。
I think he had absolutely no idea what he was getting into. I think he might have heard stories in the local taverns about the excitement of life at sea. Perhaps he heard stories that you could go to other islands and maybe meet other women. But clearly, he had no idea what he was getting into. And it seems like the reality set in very soon after he had started off on his voyage.
我想他完全不知道自己陷入了什么境地。他可能在当地酒馆里听到过关于海上生活的刺激故事。也许他听说可以去其他岛屿，遇见其他女人。但显然，他根本不知道自己要面对什么，而且在他开始航行后不久，残酷的现实似乎就显现出来了。
And this is what I love about this story is that, instead of just dreaming of this alternate life where he's a bad guy, he goes for it. And he's the worst pirate. Like, he does everything wrong. Like, for instance, the captain of the pirate ship is supposed to be the most experienced sailor.
这个故事让我着迷的地方在于，他没有仅仅梦想着那种作为坏人的替代生活，而是真正去做了。而且他是个糟糕透顶的海盗。他做错了每一件事。例如，海盗船的船长理应是经验最丰富的海员。
Yeah?
是吗？
And Bonnet has no experience sailing.
而邦尼特完全没有航海经验。
So it looks like, when he was about to attack a ship, he would have to look around and ask advice, which is not something you want to be seen doing as a captain. You want to be seen as decisive, fast, aggressive.
所以看起来，当他准备袭击一艘船时，他不得不环顾四周征求建议，这不是一个船长该做的。你应该表现得果断、迅速、有侵略性。
But they have a few successes. They take a few ships. He even gets a reputation. This is when they start calling him the Gentleman Pirate.
但他们确实取得了一些成功。他们劫持了几艘船，他甚至赢得了名声。也就是在这个时候，人们开始叫他“绅士海盗”。
Does he kill people?
他杀人吗？
No, actually. He's kind of a nice pirate. He captures people. He takes their goods. And then he lets them go.
不，事实上，他算是一个挺友善的海盗。他会俘虏人，拿走货物，然后就把人放了。
But then he attacks a big ship, a Spanish man-of-war, and over 30 of his men are killed or wounded. And it's a huge disaster. Bonnet is gravely injured. And they have to escape and flee to the Bahamas.
但后来他袭击了一艘大型西班牙军舰，结果他的30多名船员被杀或受伤。那是一场巨大的灾难。邦尼特受了重伤，他们不得不逃往巴哈马。
And there he met one of the most iconic pirates in world history, Edward Thatch, who's better known as Blackbeard.
在那里，他遇到了世界历史上最标志性的海盗之一——爱德华·萨奇（Edward Thatch），也就是众所周知的“黑胡子”。
Yeah. This is where the story takes a remarkable turn. So basically, here's this guy who has idolized pirates, and who does he happened upon but basically the most famous pirate in the world.
没错。故事就在这里发生了转折。基本上，这个一直崇拜海盗的家伙，竟然碰上了世界上最著名的海盗。
Who is, in fact, Bonnet's polar opposite. He's a successful sailor. He is aggressive. He's decisive. He's cruel. He's sadistic. But he's also charismatic and bold, as opposed to Bonnet, who's indecisive, nervous.
而且他实际上与邦尼特截然相反。他是个成功的船员，极具侵略性，果断、残忍、虐待狂。但他同时也很有魅力和胆识，而邦尼特则优柔寡断、神经质。
And Blackbeard was this consummate performer. He was incredibly violent. He was unpredictable. There's a reason he's one of the most famous pirates. Even pirates were like, whoa, this guy is out of control. When he would first appear on your ship, he would have prepared for that moment by tying these pieces of twine called slow matches into his long, big beard, and he would light them on fire just as he appeared so that there was this cloud of smoke. And in the smoke, you would just see the eyes of Blackbeard. So he looked like he was appearing out of hell.
而且“黑胡子”是个完美的表演者。他极其暴力，不可预测。他之所以成为最著名的海盗是有原因的。甚至连海盗都觉得，哇，这家伙失控了。当他第一次出现在你的船上时，他会提前准备好，把一种叫“慢燃绳”的麻绳系进他长长的大胡子里，在他现身时点火，这样就会有一团烟雾。在烟雾中，你只能看到“黑胡子”的眼睛，让他看起来像是从地狱里冒出来的一样。
I don't understand that at all. It just seems like the fire would catch fire to his beard.
我完全不能理解。那火难道不会烧着他的胡子吗？
He had a method, I'm sure.
我相信他有办法。
And this was actually a strategy. Their whole thing was to inspire as much terror as possible because, if they made you incredibly afraid, you would give up the ship without a fight.
这实际上是一种策略。他们的整套把戏就是为了制造尽可能多的恐怖，因为如果你让他们感到极度恐惧，他们就会不战而降。
Oh, this never occurred to me until this second. So the skull and crossbones and all that, it's all like a brand to make people scared.
噢，我直到这一刻才想到。所以骷髅旗之类的东西，其实就像是为了让人们害怕而建立的品牌。
Yeah. Their brand was death. They arrive with a skull and crossbones. If you think death is coming for you, you're going to surrender. But in fact, some pirates, like Blackbeard, they didn't even kill many people. In fact, there's no evidence Blackbird ever killed anyone till the very end. So it was very theatrical. They're putting on a show, and they understood that. And I like imagining these pirates scheming and plotting it out, being like, OK, no, here, I have a really good idea. This is so scary.
没错，他们的品牌就是死亡。他们打着骷髅旗而来。如果你认为死亡即将来临，你就会投降。但事实上，有些海盗，比如“黑胡子”，甚至没杀几个人。事实上，没有任何证据表明“黑胡子”在最后时刻之前杀过任何人。所以这非常有戏剧性。他们在演戏，他们深知这一点。我喜欢想象这些海盗策划这一幕的样子，他们会说：“好吧，不，这里我有个绝妙的主意。这肯定很吓人。”
So now basically, the most skilled pirate meets the least skilled.
所以现在，最资深的海盗遇上了最业余的海盗。
And Blackbeard treats Bonnet in a very friendly manner, which is uncharacteristic of Blackbeard. Bonnet is gravely injured. Blackbeard comes on board and says, I'll captain your ship.
而且“黑胡子”以一种非常友好的方式对待邦尼特，这在“黑胡子”身上很不常见。邦尼特受了重伤，“黑胡子”登船说：“我来指挥你的船吧。”
As help to you?
作为对你的帮助？
Yes.
是的。
Extremely rich man.
一个极其富有的人。
Yes.
是的。
Who doesn't know what he's doing.
一个不知道自己在做什么的人。
Exactly.
没错。
All right.
好吧。
And he lets Bonnet hang out and heal in the captain's quarters while he captains the ship.
然后他让邦尼特在船长室里休息养伤，而由他来指挥这艘船。
So do we know what Blackbeard gets out of this?
那我们知道“黑胡子”从中得到了什么吗？
We don't know. But Bonnet's a novelty. Blackbeard wouldn't have gotten a chance to ever hang out with an aristocrat. They end up being together for almost a year.
我们不知道。但邦尼特是个新鲜事物。“黑胡子”没机会和贵族混在一起。他们最终在一起待了近一年。
Wow.
哇。
And at some point, Blackbeard gives Bonnet his ship back. And when Bonnet finally goes out on his own again, he fails at pirating so badly his crew begs Blackbeard. They're like, we cannot work for this guy. He is a terrible pirate. Please take over this ship. And so Blackbeard intervenes and he puts his second-in-command in charge of Bonnet's ship and he invites Bonnet over just to stay on his ship for a while. Then he tells him, you know, you're just not cut out for this lifestyle. Just sail with me. So again, it's this ruse of like, hang out with me. Put your feet up. Relax.
后来在某个时候，“黑胡子”把船还给了邦尼特。当邦尼特终于再次独自出发时，他的海盗生涯又失败得一塌糊涂，以至于船员们去求“黑胡子”。他们说：“我们没法在这个家伙手下干活。他是个糟糕的海盗。请接管这艘船吧。”于是“黑胡子”介入了，他让自己的大副接管了邦尼特的船，并邀请邦尼特去他的船上待一段时间。然后告诉他：“你知道，你真的不适合这种生活方式。就跟我一起航行吧。”所以这又是那种花招，就像是“跟我待在一起。休息一下，放松一下。”
This was a transformative moment for Bonnet. I think this was a moment when he realized he made a huge mistake. In fact, Captain Charles Johnson recalled that he, at this moment, saw his folly and, quote, "he reflected upon his past course of life and was confounded with shame when he thought upon what he had done." So he clearly fell into a deep, deep depression.
这对邦尼特来说是一个转变时刻。我认为在这一刻他意识到自己犯了个大错。事实上，查尔斯·约翰逊船长回忆说，他在那一刻看到了自己的愚蠢，并引述道：“他反思了自己过去的生活，想到自己所做的一切，感到羞愧难当。”所以他显然陷入了深深的抑郁中。
Because he was like, oh, I had a midlife crisis and I left my wife and three kids, and now I'm a pirate. And I'm horrible at it.
因为他当时心想：“噢，我经历了中年危机，抛弃了妻子和三个孩子，现在成了一个海盗。而且我干得烂透了。”
Yes, that's exactly right. In fact, he tells the rest of the pirates that he actually really regrets actually becoming a pirate. And the rest of the pirates are embarrassed just to look at him.
是的，完全正确。事实上，他告诉其他海盗，他真的很后悔成为海盗。而其他海盗看着他都觉得丢人。
Yeah. And in fact, one of the historical accounts said that, when he ventured out on deck, he wore an elegant morning gown and usually carried the book he was reading in his hands, and then he would sort of sulk with despair.
是的。事实上，历史记载中说，当他走到甲板上时，他穿着优雅的晨袍，手里通常拿着他正在读的书，然后就会带着绝望闷闷不乐。
So he has all this regret about being a pirate. And then something incredible happens, which is that the king issues this decree that there is a pardon available for pirates and you can return to your life without any criminal charges. So when they get to port, he takes the pardon. And Bonnet's plan is to become a privateer.
所以他对自己当海盗感到无比后悔。然后发生了一件不可思议的事，那就是国王颁布了一项法令，宣布海盗可以获得赦免，你可以回到原来的生活而无需承担任何刑事责任。所以当他们抵达港口时，他接受了赦免。而邦尼特的计划是成为一名私掠船长。
What's that?
那是什么？
It's like a mercenary navy that works for the king.
就像是为国王效力的雇佣兵海军。
OK.
好吧。
But when he gets back to his ship, Blackbeard has betrayed him.
但当他回到自己的船上时，“黑胡子”背叛了他。
That is so not a surprise at all.
那一点也不让人意外。
He's plundered his ship and he's taken his men and marooned them on a deserted island, and he leaves them for dead. Bonnet saves them.
他洗劫了这艘船，带走了他的船员，并将他们遗弃在一个荒岛上，让他们自生自灭。邦尼特救了他们。
He is really furious at Blackbeard and, in fact, decides he wants to go after and capture Blackbeard himself, which is, as you can imagine, an astounding misperception of his own skill sets. Here's this guy who had minor success. His crew never respected him. Goes after probably one of the most successful pirates in world history, who is much more aggressive, and thinks that somehow he's going to enact revenge and he's finally living up to the name of his ship for the first time.
他非常愤怒，甚至决定亲自去追捕并俘获“黑胡子”，正如你所能想象的，这是对他自己能力水平的一种惊人的误判。这家伙只取得过微小的成功，船员从未尊重过他，却要去追捕大概是世界历史上最成功、也更具侵略性的海盗之一，还天真地认为自己能复仇成功，这也是他第一次真正活出了他那艘船的名字。
So he's back in the game.
所以他又重操旧业了。
Yeah. He never actually catches Blackbeard. But while he's chasing him, he finally becomes a real pirate. He takes 13 ships. He got violent. He flogged his own men. He threatened to burn down a whole town and to shoot his own crew if they surrendered. And in the final battle, where he was captured, he and his men kill 18 people.
是的。他其实从未抓到“黑胡子”。但在追捕过程中，他终于变成了一个真正的海盗。他劫掠了13艘船。他变得残暴起来，鞭打自己的船员，还威胁要烧毁整个城镇，如果船员投降就杀了他们。在被俘虏的最后一场战斗中，他和他的船员杀了18个人。
So you could say that he had some, I guess, personal growth. Learned specific lessons from Blackbeard. Learned that, if you're going to do this, you have to put on the show and you've got to actually appear to be someone who it is worth surrendering to. Yeah, so Bonnet eventually has matured into a murderous pirate.
所以可以说他取得了一些，我想是个人成长。从“黑胡子”那里学到了具体的一课。学到了如果你要干这一行，你必须演好这场戏，并且你必须看起来是一个值得对方投降的人。没错，所以邦尼特最终成熟为一个残暴的海盗。
Wait. So he had a romantic idea of what it was like to be somebody who murders people and takes their stuff, and then he actually ends up actually murdering people and taking their stuff?
等等。所以他曾对杀人抢劫的生活抱有浪漫的幻想，结果最终他真的杀人并抢劫了？
Yeah.
是的。
That's horrible.
那真是太可怕了。
Yeah. He becomes a bad guy. And they catch him. And they put him on trial.
是的。他变成了坏人。然后他们抓住了他，并对他进行了审判。
So he finally got his wish. The world finally thought he was a pirate. Like, mission accomplished.
所以他终于如愿以偿了。世界最终认为他是个海盗。就像是，任务完成了。
Yeah. And now he can be hanged at 30. And there's actually a transcript of his trial.
是的。现在他要在30岁时被绞死。其实还有他的审判记录。
So did he admit being a pirate? Was he proud?
那他承认自己是海盗吗？他感到自豪吗？
No. He pled not guilty. He said his crew held him on board against his will and that he wasn't doing any of the piracy. And apparently, this kind of defense is typical. Mark Hanna told me pirates usually deny that they're pirates, or they rationalize it, like there's some good reason that they did this. They were poor sailors or they were badly treated, and it was only fair to start stealing from these big trading companies' ships.
没有。他拒不认罪。他说他的船员是在违背他意愿的情况下把他扣在船上的，他并没有参与任何海盗行为。显然，这种辩护在海盗中很典型。马克·汉纳告诉我，海盗通常会否认自己是海盗，或者进行合理化解释，仿佛他们这么做是有正当理由的。他们会说自己是苦命的水手或者受到了不公正待遇，所以从这些大贸易公司的船上偷东西只是为了公平。
So did the defense work? Did he get off?
那辩护有效吗？他脱罪了吗？
No. He went to the gallows in Charleston, South Carolina. There's actually a marker in a park there.
没有。他最终在南卡罗来纳州的查尔斯顿被送上绞刑架。那里的公园里甚至有一个纪念牌。
So the guy goes and hangs out with pirates. And even though he does not seem to have the smallest aptitude for pirating, he still ends up becoming a pirate.
所以这家伙跑去和海盗混在一起。即使他看起来一点海盗的天赋都没有，最终还是变成了一个海盗。
Today on our program we hear the story of another guy-- a guy who's alive right now, a guy today-- who gets near to pirates. Did it change him? We try to figure that out. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Arrr you going to stay with us? No, we're not using that!
今天我们的节目将讲述另一个人的故事——一个活在当下的人，一个与海盗有交集的人。这改变了他吗？我们试着找出答案。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。你还要留下来吗？不，我们不玩那个梗！
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Act One, Pirate Change Denier.
第一幕：海盗行为的否认者。
You may remember hearing about Rachel and Paul Chandler a few years back. They're a British couple who were spending their retirement sailing around the world. But in October, 2009, in the middle of the night, a band of Somali pirates boarded their boat with guns and kidnapped them for ransom. They were held for months in the Somali bush, where they were threatened and fed a steady diet of goat liver.
你可能还记得几年前听过雷切尔（Rachel）和保罗·钱德勒（Paul Chandler）夫妇的事。他们是一对正在环球航行的英国退休夫妇。但在2009年10月的一个深夜，一群索马里海盗手持枪支登上了他们的船，并将他们绑架索要赎金。他们在索马里的丛林里被扣押了几个月，遭受威胁，伙食只有羊肝。
Back in England, Rachel's brother, a guy named Stephen Collett was negotiating with the pirates. He spent eight months trying to work out a deal mostly with a pirate called Ali. They finally came to an agreement. $440,000 for Rachel and Paul's freedom. A contract was written up and signed and faxed to Ali's office in Somalia. Some pirates have offices and fax machines.
在英国，雷切尔的哥哥斯蒂芬·科莱特（Stephen Collett）负责与海盗谈判。他花了八个月时间试图与一个叫阿里（Ali）的海盗达成交易。他们最终达成一致：440,000美元换取雷切尔和保罗的自由。一份合同被草拟并签署，传真到了阿里在索马里的办公室。有些海盗甚至有办公室和传真机。
And then the day before Rachel and Paul were scheduled to be released, the pirates let Stephen talk directly to Paul.
然后在雷切尔和保罗预定获释的前一天，海盗让斯蒂芬直接与保罗通话。
We have made arrangements, Paul, to deliver the money to the pirates by plane to a town called Adado tomorrow at 11 o'clock.
我们已经做好了安排，保罗，明天11点将钱通过飞机送到一个叫阿达多（Adado）的小镇。
Yeah? 11 o'clock?
是吗？11点？
Yes. Yes. Now, if the plane cannot land again to collect you, then you will stay with a Mr. Mohamed Aden tomorrow night in Adado.
是的。是的。现在，如果飞机不能再次降落接你，那么明天晚上你将和穆罕默德·亚丁（Mohamed Aden）先生一起待在阿达多。
Mohamed Aden?
穆罕默德·亚丁？
Yes. In Adado. Now, Mohamed Aden is the district governor who lives in Adado, and he's not a pirate. I repeat, he is not a pirate.
是的。在阿达多。现在，穆罕默德·亚丁是住在阿达多的地区州长，他不是海盗。我重复一遍，他不是海盗。
OK. Yes. That's good.
好的。是的。那很好。
He is working on our side. He is a good man and you can trust him.
他站在我们这边。他是个好人，你可以信任他。
Mohamed Aden, the guy Stephen mentions, who's the governor of a region in Somalia where Rachel and Paul were held, he's actually American. Somali-American. He was born in Mogadishu but spent half his life in Minneapolis. Most people call him by his nickname, Tiiceey. And when Stephen says--
斯蒂芬提到的穆罕默德·亚丁，也就是雷切尔和保罗被扣押的索马里地区的州长，其实是个美国人。索马里裔美国人。他在摩加迪沙出生，但在明尼阿波利斯度过了半生。大多数人叫他的昵称“Tiiceey”。当斯蒂芬说——
He is not a pirate. I repeat, he is not a pirate.
他不是海盗。我重复一遍，他不是海盗。
That's actually the question of this story. Tiiceey took a public stand against piracy, worked to end piracy in his area. But right now, he's locked up in a Belgian prison. He was arrested for piracy and for criminal organization. He denies the charges. Though, of course, as you just heard, denying you're a pirate is an old tradition in pirating.
这正是这个故事的核心问题。“Tiiceey”曾公开反对海盗行为，并致力于消除该地区的海盗。但现在，他被关在比利时监狱里。他因海盗罪和组织犯罪被捕。他否认这些指控。当然，正如你刚才听到的，否认自己是海盗是海盗界的一项古老传统。
So is he innocent? Is he a pirate? Is he colluding with pirates? And if he is, how does a guy who comes all the way from America with the best of intentions, hoping to do the right things, end up in this situation? One of our producers, Dana Chivvis, looked into it.
所以他是无辜的吗？他是海盗吗？他是在与海盗勾结吗？如果是这样，一个怀揣善意、希望能做正确事情的人，怎么会从美国走到这一步？我们的制片人之一达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）对此进行了调查。
Tiiceey used to be just another boring dad in Minnesota. In 2008, he was finishing a master's degree in public administration at Minnesota State and starting a small health services company. He lived in a three-bedroom condo in the suburbs of Minneapolis with his wife, Shamso, and their five sons. He was a regular Walmart-shopping, football-loving, homework-checking father.
Tiiceey过去只是明尼苏达州一个平平无奇的父亲。2008年，他正在明尼苏达州立大学攻读公共管理硕士学位，并开始经营一家小型健康服务公司。他和妻子莎姆索（Shamso）以及他们的五个儿子住在明尼阿波利斯郊区的一套三居室公寓里。他是一个像普通人一样在沃尔玛购物、喜欢橄榄球、检查孩子作业的父亲。
He was also active in the Somali community in Minneapolis, and he did the thing that do-gooder ex-pats do. He raised money from other members of his clan to send back home. He tried to improve things back in Somalia.
他也积极参与明尼苏达州的索马里社区事务，做着那些热心的外籍人士会做的事情：向族人筹款并寄回国内，试图改善索马里的状况。
Clans run Somalia. There's no powerful central government there. And Tiiceey's clan is made up of hundreds of thousands of people. In 2008, the clan was trying to restore order to the part of the country they're from, a region called Himan and Heeb, a 5,000-square-mile patch of sand that hadn't had a functioning government since the early '90s. A place with no running water, rife with bandits and warlords, where camel herders wandered the desert and pirates plundered the seas. Where you couldn't drive from one town to another because the warring tribes wouldn't allow it.
索马里由各个家族管理。那里没有强大的中央政府。Tiiceey的家族有几十万人。2008年，该家族试图在他们家乡地区——希曼和希布（Himan and Heeb）——恢复秩序。那是一块5,000平方英里的沙地，自90年代初以来就没有运作良好的政府。那里没有自来水，到处是土匪和军阀，牧驼人在沙漠中徘徊，海盗掠夺海洋。你甚至无法从一个城镇开车到另一个城镇，因为交战的部落不允许。
So members of the clan from all over the world gathered in Dubai to come up with a plan to create a government there. Tiiceey went to that conference. He says he was actually picked to run the meeting. And he did such a good job, the clan elders drafted him to be part of a small team that would actually move to Himan and Heeb for three months, write a constitution, and get a government started. He's the guy who has trouble saying no, so he flew to Africa directly from the conference.
于是来自世界各地的家族成员齐聚迪拜，商讨在那里建立政府的计划。Tiiceey也参加了那次会议。他说他实际上被选中主持会议，而且表现得非常出色，族中长老起草让他加入一个小团队，真正搬到希曼和希布待上三个月，写出宪法，并让政府运转起来。他是一个很难拒绝别人请求的人，所以他直接从会议地点飞往非洲。
So wait. They didn't let you go back? You couldn't go back to Minneapolis?
等等。他们没让你回来？你不能回到明尼阿波利斯？
No.
不能。
You went--
你去了——
Unfortunately, no.
不幸的是，不能。
--straight to Somalia.
——直接去了索马里。
Because they were afraid if we go back home we would never come back.
因为他们担心如果我们回去了，就永远不会再来了。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
Yes. So in a way, it was a setup.
是的，所以从某种意义上说，这是一个圈套。
Yeah, it was a setup. You were conscripted.
没错，这是一个圈套。你被强征入伍了。
Yes.
是的。
At the end of those three months, he'd done such a good job that the local elders asked him to stay and run the place for a few years. He didn't want to do it, lobbied against it for a week. But his friends finally sat him down and said, you have no choice. If any of us had been asked, we'd do it. So he agreed.
那三个月结束时，他工作得非常出色，当地长老要求他留下来管理那里几年。他不想做，游说了一周试图推辞。但他的朋友们终于让他坐下来说：“你别无选择。如果是我们中的任何一个人被要求，我们都会去做。”所以他同意了。
The day they appointed me, that was my scariest day in my entire life.
任命我的那天，是我一生中最可怕的一天。
He's saying it was the scariest day in his entire life. That's Tiiceey talking to me in January. He's calling me from the prison in Belgium, so it's a little hard to hear.
他说那他一生中最可怕的一天。这是Tiiceey一月份对我说的。他是从比利时的监狱里给我打电话的，所以听得有点吃力。
I was scared like a little girl.
我当时像个小女孩一样害怕。
Do you remember calling Shamso and telling her this news?
你记得给莎姆索打电话告诉她这个消息吗？
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Actually, what I did is-- I could not face-- to be honest with you, she's what's called the boss. She's the one who wears the pants in the house.
事实上，我做的是——我无法面对——说实话，她是家里所谓的“老板”。她在家里当家作主。
He says it was hard to bring himself to tell his wife, so he asked his friends to call her, figuring she couldn't say no to them.
他说很难开口告诉妻子，所以他请求朋友们给她打电话，心想她肯定无法拒绝他们。
I was a coward. I didn't have the balls.
我是个懦夫。我没胆子说。
At first, he told his wife, Shamso, he'd only be gone a few months. But now he had to explain to her-- well, his friends did, actually-- that he was going to stay in Somalia for a few years, leaving her with five boys to manage back in Minneapolis while he lived in a lawless country they'd both fled years ago. When I asked him what his goals were in Somalia, he said he didn't want to die.
起初，他告诉妻子莎姆索他只会离开几个月。但现在他不得不向她解释——好吧，其实是他的朋友们解释的——他要在索马里待上几年，留下她一个人在明尼阿波利斯管理五个男孩，而他则住在他俩多年前逃离的那个无法无天的国家。当我问他在索马里的目标是什么时，他说他不想死。
First of all, my dream was not to die here. Not to die there. But work wise, my dream was to make the situation the best I can. To make safe, to build a good buildings, you know, roads, like a lot of people working and there's a lot of income. But it was a dream.
首先，我的梦想不是死在那里。但在工作方面，我的梦想是让情况尽可能好转。让那里安全，建造好的建筑，你知道，修路，让很多人有工作，有很多收入。但这只是个梦想。
I've been talking to Tiiceey since December when I visited him at the prison in Belgium. It's a massive and foreboding place with a moat, for some reason. Tiiceey doesn't look like a pirate. He looks like a professor. He's 6 feet tall and a little chubby. He's 44 years old with a goatee that's starting to grey.
自从去年12月我去比利时的监狱探望Tiiceey以来，我就一直在和他交谈。那是一个巨大且阴森的地方，不知为何还有一条护城河。Tiiceey看起来不像海盗。他看起来像个教授。他身高6英尺，有点微胖。他44岁了，山羊胡子开始变白。
And since we met, he's been calling me from a phone in the lounge area of his cell block. We've spent hours talking about his work in Somalia and his legal case. There's always a TV on in the background so it can get a little tough to hear.
从我们见面以来，他一直从牢房休息区的电话里给我打电话。我们花了几个小时谈论他在索马里的工作和他的法律案件。背景里总是有电视在响，所以听起来有点吃力。
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Dana. Good evening.
嘿，达娜。晚上好。
Hey, Tiiceey. How are you doing?
嘿，Tiiceey。你最近怎么样？
Good, yes. How you doing?
好，是的。你呢？
I like talking to Tiiceey. He's smart and he has a good sense of humor. At one point, we were trying to figure out how much these phone calls cost. He thought they were really expensive.
我喜欢和Tiiceey聊天。他很聪明，也很有幽默感。有一次，我们试着算算这些电话费是多少。他觉得特别贵。
$5.75.
5.75美元。
So $5.75 a minute is the best price?
所以每分钟5.75美元是最好的价格？
Oh, my god. It's a rip-off. It's like calling Antarctica or somewhere. No, man, it's not.
噢，天哪。简直是抢钱。就像打给南极洲什么的。不，伙计，不是这样的。
And they're accusing you of piracy.
而且他们指控你海盗罪。
Look at that. Touche. Touche.
看看这个。将了一军。将了一军。
Turns out, by the way, Tiiceey overestimated. The calls were much less than that. Only about $1 and change. Overestimating might be a character flaw of his, as you'll hear.
顺便说一句，Tiiceey高估了。电话费没那么贵。只有1美元多一点。过高估计可能是一个性格缺陷，你会听到的。
So here's the story he told me about how he went into Somalia full of hope and good intentions and ended up in the clink in Belgium. Tiiceey's first priority as governor of Himan and Heeb was to hire police and set up a court system. He knew he couldn't make any progress unless there was some security in the area. He hired police and paid them $50 a month. He told me he didn't pay his small administrative staff a salary at first because he wanted to save the little money he had for the police and the judges. Make sure they'd stay on his side.
所以这是他告诉我的故事：他如何怀揣希望和善意进入索马里，最终却蹲进了比利时的牢房。Tiiceey作为希曼和希布州长的第一要务是雇佣警察并建立法院系统。他知道除非该地区有安全保障，否则他无法取得任何进展。他雇佣了警察并每月支付50美元。他告诉我，他起初没有给他的小型行政人员发薪水，因为他想把仅有的那点钱留给警察和法官，确保他们站在他这一边。
Tiiceey was setting up a government from scratch, so it's not like everyone just accepted the new order. His first month there, the court heard a land dispute. Two men claimed to own the same piece of property, and the guy who lost the case was pretty unhappy about it. So he and a bunch of relatives with guns surrounded the disputed land. Tiiceey's soldiers showed up and the occupiers--
Tiiceey是从零开始建立政府，所以并不是每个人都接受这种新秩序。他到那里的第一个月，法院审理了一起土地纠纷。两个人声称拥有同一块房产，败诉的那个家伙非常不满。于是他和一帮拿着枪的亲戚包围了这块地。Tiiceey的士兵赶到了，占领者——
They opened fire. And one of my soldiers died.
他们开了枪。我的一名士兵死了。
Tiiceey's men ended up killing three of the occupiers.
Tiiceey的人最终杀死了三名占领者。
I'm not proud of killing people, but that was actually the turning point of the respect that we get. That's the day the administration became a real administration.
我不以杀人为傲，但这实际上是我们获得尊重的转折点。也就是在那一天，行政机构成为了一个真正的行政机构。
After that incident, people started to respect Tiiceey's new administration. He had authority now. He was writing laws and he was able to enforce them, but it was still pretty scary.
在那次事件之后，人们开始尊重Tiiceey的新政府。他现在有了权力。他在制定法律并执行，但情况仍然很吓人。
Every morning when you wake up you're thinking about how I'm going to die today. If I'm going to die, am I going to die with bullets? Am I going to die with [INAUDIBLE]? Am I going to die with suicide? Am I going to die with my staff killing me? Seriously. And that's the environment you're working on.
每天早上醒来，你都在想今天我会怎么死。如果我注定要死，我是会被子弹打死吗？我会死于……？我会死于自杀吗？我会死于我的手下杀我吗？说真的。这就是你工作的环境。
What I do on a daily basis is to solve the problems for the people, whether it is lack of food or it's water.
我每天所做的工作就是解决人民的问题，无论是缺食物还是缺水。
That's Tiiceey talking to a New York Times video journalist in 2009, a year after he started the government.
那是Tiiceey 2009年在接受《纽约时报》视频记者采访时说的话，那是在他开始执政一年后。
In other work, you can't measure your success, but this is very easy to measure for success. You can see in the people's eyes that you helped them and you feel good. You feel good about that.
在其他工作中，你无法衡量你的成功，但这个衡量成功非常容易。你可以从人们的眼里看到你帮助了他们，你会感觉很好。你会为此感到欣慰。
That interview happened because a New York Times reporter named Jeffrey Gettleman caught wind of the changes happening in Adado and he decided to go see for himself. To get there, he had to hire one militia for the start of the journey, who handed him off to a second militia who drove him the rest of the way into Adado.
那次采访是因为《纽约时报》记者杰弗里·格特尔曼（Jeffrey Gettleman）听到了阿达多正在发生的变化，于是他决定去一探究竟。为了到达那里，他不得不雇佣了一支民兵护送行程的一半，然后又交接给第二支民兵，由他们开车载他剩下的路进入阿达多。
So as we pulled in, we saw lots of new construction, lots of houses with brand new, shiny metal roofs, a relatively new school, new stores, lights. It was like an oasis of development in the middle of a very neglected, remote area.
当我们驶入时，我们看到了大量新的建筑，许多房屋盖着闪闪发亮的新金属屋顶，有一所相对较新的学校、新商店、灯光。这就像在贫瘠偏远地区中间出现的一片发展绿洲。
Did you feel safer there than you did in your other trips around Somalia?
你在那里是否比在索马里其他地方旅行时感觉更安全？
I felt pretty safe there. And maybe that was totally ridiculous, but I felt safe there because I trusted Tiiceey. And he had control. I had been in Somalia enough I could tell who was the real deal and who was a pretender, and he seemed like the real deal.
我在那里感觉很安全。也许这完全荒谬，但我感觉很安全，因为我信任Tiiceey。他有控制力。我在索马里待得够久，能分辨谁是真才实干，谁是滥竽充数，而他看起来确实是真才实干。
But Tiiceey still had one major problem to tackle: pirates.
但Tiiceey仍然有一个主要问题需要解决：海盗。
They were more powerful than anyone else at that time.
他们是当时比任何人都强大的力量。
The years that Tiiceey was governor, 2008 until 2013, that's when the piracy epidemic was raging in Somalia. In fact, piracy was so pervasive that it was basically its own industry-- one that cost the world economy billions each year. In 2010, more than 1,000 people were taken hostage at sea. Nobody, not the Somali federal government or rich Western nations, had been able to roust them. Tiiceey's region was home to one of the most notorious pirate towns in Somalia, a place called Harardhere.
Tiiceey担任州长的这几年（2008年到2013年），正是索马里海盗肆虐的时候。事实上，海盗行为极其普遍，基本上成为了一种产业，每年给全球经济造成数十亿美元的损失。2010年，超过1,000人在海上被劫持。没有人，无论是索马里联邦政府还是富裕的西方国家，能够铲除他们。Tiiceey的地区是索马里最臭名昭著的海盗城镇之一的所在地，一个叫哈拉尔代雷（Harardhere）的地方。
Tiiceey set up local governments in other towns in the region, but when he went to Harardhere, the elders there told him not to bother. The pirates controlled everything. They'd even set up a pirate stock exchange there in the building where anyone could go and buy shares in a pirate venture. They had more guns and more men and more money than Tiiceey did, and they weren't going to listen to him.
Tiiceey在当地其他城镇建立了地方政府，但当他去哈拉尔代雷时，那里的长老让他别费劲了。海盗控制了一切。他们甚至在楼里建立了一个海盗证券交易所，任何人都可以去购买海盗投资的股份。他们的枪支、人手和资金都比Tiiceey多，他们根本不会听他的。
In April of 2009, Tiiceey says he met with the president of Somalia and told him he needed help fighting the pirates. Luckily, the president had worked to eradicate piracy himself in the same area in 2006 and it had worked for a little while. The president knew someone who could help Tiiceey-- a guy called Mohamed Abdi Hassan. He goes by the nickname Afweyne, which means "big mouth."
2009年4月，Tiiceey说他会见了索马里总统，并告诉他他需要帮助来对抗海盗。幸运的是，总统自己在2006年也曾致力于铲除同一地区的海盗，而且奏效了一段时间。总统认识一个能帮助Tiiceey的人——一个叫穆罕默德·阿卜迪·哈桑（Mohamed Abdi Hassan）的家伙。他的昵称是“阿夫韦内”（Afweyne），意思是“大嘴巴”。
He was a Somali businessman and also the godfather of modern Somali piracy. Afweyne is the guy who figured out that you could run a piracy business like any other legitimate business-- by raising capital from investors and then funding piracy ventures on the high seas.
他是一位索马里商人，也是现代索马里海盗的教父。阿夫韦内就是那个意识到你可以像运营任何合法生意一样经营海盗业务的人——通过从投资者那里募集资本，然后资助公海上的海盗活动。
Did you have the thought of, like, why would I hire a guy who's a big pirate to run my anti-piracy campaign?
你有没有想过，为什么要雇一个大海盗来运营我的反海盗行动？
To be honest with you-- I'm not hiding anything-- but at that time, he was a businessman.
说实话——我没有任何隐瞒——但在当时，他是个商人。
So he wasn't hijacking ships?
所以他没有劫持船只？
No, no. He was [INAUDIBLE]. He had an office in Harardhere at that time. He was bringing khat. Khat.
没有，没有。他在……他当时在哈拉尔代雷有办公室。他在运送恰特草。恰特草。
Khat. Oh, that was his business.
恰特草。噢，那是他的生意。
Khat is a leaf that gives you a little buzz when you chew it. It's legal in Somalia, and pirates apparently chew the stuff all day long.
恰特草是一种咀嚼后能带来微醺感的叶子。它在索马里是合法的，海盗们似乎整天都在嚼这玩意儿。
What was Afweyne-- as a member of the committee, what was he actually doing?
阿夫韦内作为委员会的一员，他实际上在做什么？
He knew most of those guys, especially the middlemen. He knows a lot.
他认识那些家伙中的大多数，尤其是中间人。他知道很多。
Most of the middleman pirates.
大多数海盗中间人。
Yes, yes, even the kingpins. He knows a lot because most of them used to work for him.
是的，是的，甚至是大佬。他知道很多，因为他们中的大多数人都曾为他工作。
If this doesn't seem like the greatest idea, to hire one of the most notorious pirates to help you end piracy, Tiiceey said he didn't have much of a choice. And actually, Afweyne turned out to be really helpful. This was their plan.
如果这看起来不是什么好主意，雇一个最臭名昭著的海盗来帮你终结海盗行为，Tiiceey说他别无选择。事实上，阿夫韦内证明非常有帮助。这是他们的计划。
Step one, pirate shaming. Convince the local imams to start teaching people that piracy is forbidden in the Koran so the pirates become ostracized.
第一步，海盗羞辱。说服当地阿訇开始教导人们海盗行为在《古兰经》中是被禁止的，这样海盗就会被孤立。
Step two, create an economic incentive. Give the pirates other job opportunities that don't require hijacking and kidnapping-- like maybe create a market for fish.
第二步，创造经济激励。给海盗提供不需要劫持和绑架的其他工作机会——比如建立一个鱼类市场。
Step three, pirate rehabilitation. When they caught the lower-level pirates, the foot soldiers, Tiiceey sent them to a rehabilitation camp. Taught them new job skills, including how to read and write. And with the pirate bosses, the kingpins, Tiiceey had one especially attractive incentive to offer them to get them to quit the business. Immunity. Which, Tiiceey points out, only applies to the Somali government. It doesn't mean the US or Britain or Belgium, for instance, couldn't capture them later. But he doesn't mention that part to them.
第三步，海盗改造。当他们抓到低级海盗、普通士兵时，Tiiceey把他们送到康复营。教给他们新的工作技能，包括如何读写。至于海盗老板、大佬们，Tiiceey有一个特别诱人的激励手段让他们退出海盗行当：豁免权。Tiiceey指出，这只适用于索马里政府。这并不意味着美国、英国或比利时等国不能事后逮捕他们。但他没对他们提这一部分。
You think I never lied to them? I lied. I lied. I tell them many lies.
你觉得我从来没对他们撒过谎？我撒了谎。我撒了谎。我告诉他们很多谎话。
You told the pirates many lies, the kingpins many lies?
你告诉海盗很多谎话，告诉大佬们很多谎话？
Of course, yes. I tell them many lies to get them.
当然，是的。我告诉他们很多谎话来引诱他们。
To get them out of hiding.
引诱他们从藏身处出来。
Exactly. You have to lie because this is your livelihood. You want this to finish. You want this to be your legacy.
没错。你必须撒谎，因为这是你的生计。你想让这一切结束。你想让这成为你的遗产。
By 2012, pirate attacks on big ships had effectively stopped in all of Somalia. A lot of that had to do with stuff that was happening on the water. Foreign navies were patrolling the ocean. And maritime companies started putting armed security on their boats and sailing faster and further from the coast.
到2012年，大型船只的海盗袭击在整个索马里实际上已经停止。这很大程度上与海上发生的事情有关。外国海军在海洋上巡逻。航运公司开始在他们的船上配备武装安保，并以更快的速度在远离海岸的地方航行。
And in Himan and Heeb in December, 2012, Tiiceey held a press conference, where he sat onstage as a bunch of local pirates publicly retired in front of cameras and reporters in return for immunity. It was a huge moment for him.
在希曼和希布，2012年12月，Tiiceey举行了一场新闻发布会，他坐在台上，一群当地海盗为了获得豁免权，在摄像机和记者面前公开退役。这对他来说是一个巨大的时刻。
It was a good legacy. It was the biggest thing I'd ever done, other than I introduced the region to peace, order, and good governance. So that's something.
这是一种好的遗产。这是我做过的最大的事情，除了我为这个地区带来了和平、秩序和良好的治理。所以这算是一点成就。
A few months after the press conference, Tiiceey got an email out of the blue from a guy called Yunus Collier, who was with a film company in Europe. He said they wanted to make a documentary about piracy and they wanted to talk to Tiiceey about how he dealt with the pirates in Himan and Heeb. Tiiceey agreed to meet in New York for a few days to talk about the project. The filmmakers put him up at the Trump International Hotel and Tower right on Central Park.
新闻发布会几个月后，Tiiceey突然收到了一封来自一个叫尤努斯·科利尔（Yunus Collier）的人的电子邮件，他是欧洲一家电影公司的。他说他们想拍摄一部关于海盗的纪录片，想和Tiiceey谈谈他是如何处理希曼和希布的海盗的。Tiiceey同意在纽约见面谈几天项目。电影制片人把他安置在就在中央公园旁边的川普国际酒店大厦。
The first morning there, Yunus shows up. Ti noticed he was a little hyper and his clothes weren't as nice as he was expecting. So Tiiceey teases him.
在那里的第一天早上，尤努斯出现了。Tiiceey注意到他有点亢奋，而且他的衣服不像他预期的那样考究。所以Tiiceey取笑他。
You don't dress like you are in a film company.
你的穿着看起来不像是在电影公司工作。
Right. It wasn't fancy.
对。没那么光鲜。
Because usually, it wasn't fancy. I can't see that. So I joked about, you don't dress like you are working in--
因为通常，没那么光鲜。我看不出那点。所以我开玩笑说，你的穿着看起来不像是在——
In film.
在电影界工作。
I've got to go.
我得走了。
Oh, OK.
噢，好吧。
Monday I will call you.
周一我会给你打电话。
OK.
好的。
Have a good trip, OK?
祝你旅途愉快，好吗？
Thanks so much, Tiiceey. Have a good w-- have a nice-- I don't know. I guess have a nice weekend. You're in prison, but.
非常感谢，Tiiceey。祝你有一个好的周……好的。我不知道。我想祝你有一个愉快的周末。虽然你在监狱里。
You can say that.
你可以这么说。
OK.
好的。
Sometimes I forget he's in prison. Anyway, we got back to the story a few days later. Tiiceey says Yunus's boss was there also. They spent three days together. Took Tiiceey on a helicopter ride around Manhattan and out for nice meals. Eventually, Yunus got down to business. He wanted Tiiceey and Afweyne to be consultants on the film.
有时候我都忘了他在监狱里。总之，我们几天后回到了故事里。Tiiceey说尤努斯的上司也在场。他们在一起待了三天。带Tiiceey坐直升机在曼哈顿上空飞行，还去吃了好餐。最终，尤努斯切入正题。他希望Tiiceey和阿夫韦内担任电影的顾问。
He said, that is what we want. We've got to show you a script. And he says that we're going to pay you your time.
他说，这就是我们想要的。我们必须给你看剧本。他说我们要为你的时间付费。
How much were they going to pay you?
他们打算付给你多少钱？
They said, we're going to pay, if the project had finished and everything finished, $200,000 each.
他们说，如果项目完成了，所有事情都结束了，每人付20万美元。
Oh, my god. That's so much money.
噢，天哪。那真是很多钱。
Yes. Yeah, $200,000 each, going to pay that.
是的。是的，每人20万美元，会支付这个数目。
Tiiceey agreed. They had one last meal at the Grand Central Oyster Bar. The filmmakers asked Tiiceey to convince Afweyne to help, too. And once Afweyne was on board, they'd all meet in Europe for a week, where they'd get to work. Seven days in Europe, $200,000 each to consult on a film about pirates. Pirates. Who could refuse?
Tiiceey同意了。他们在中央车站牡蛎酒吧吃了最后一顿饭。电影制片人请求Tiiceey说服阿夫韦内也加入。一旦阿夫韦内加入，他们就都会去欧洲待一周，在那里开始工作。在欧洲待七天，每人20万美元咨询一部关于海盗的电影。海盗。谁能拒绝？
Tiiceey and Afweyne landed in Brussels a month later. When they showed their passports, there was something wrong with Afweyne's visa. They were escorted to airport police.
Tiiceey和阿夫韦内一个月后降落在布鲁塞尔。当他们出示护照时，阿夫韦内的签证出了点问题。他们被护送到了机场警察局。
My gut feeling tells me that I'm in trouble.
我的直觉告诉我我有麻烦了。
Really?
真的吗？
Whatever it is. Yes. So after one hour, federal police came and he introduced himself. He says, my name is Van Osselaer. I'm the federal police. And I am here to take your freedom away.
不管是什么。是的。所以一个小时后，联邦警察来了，他自我介绍。他说，我叫范·奥塞拉尔（Van Osselaer）。我是联邦警察。我来这里是为了剥夺你的自由。
It was all a ruse. All of it was fake. Yunus Collier, the meetings in New York, the documentary film about eradicating piracy. It was the Belgian federal police the whole time. An elaborate plan to lure Afweyne to Belgium, where they could arrest him and prosecute him for the hijacking of a Belgian ship called The Pompeii.
这一切都是圈套。全是假的。尤努斯·科利尔、纽约的会议、铲除海盗的纪录片。全程都是比利时联邦警察。这是一个精心策划的计划，旨在诱骗阿夫韦内来到比利时，在那里他们可以逮捕他，并以劫持一艘名为“庞贝号”（The Pompeii）的比利时船只为由起诉他。
The Pompeii was taken in April, 2009, which was actually just a few months before Afweyne joined up with Tiiceey to fight piracy. The Belgians found Afweyne's DNA on a coffee cup in the captain's cabin of The Pompeii. They'd used Tiiceey to get to Afweyne. Tiiceey's lawyer says the Belgians weren't after Tiiceey at all. But in their excitement over catching Afweyne, they got carried away and locked Tiiceey up, too.
“庞贝号”是在2009年4月被劫持的，实际上就在阿夫韦内加入Tiiceey打击海盗前几个月。比利时人在“庞贝号”船长舱的咖啡杯上发现了阿夫韦内的DNA。他们利用Tiiceey来诱捕阿夫韦内。Tiiceey的律师说比利时人根本不是冲着Tiiceey来的。但在抓捕阿夫韦内的兴奋中，他们冲昏了头脑，把Tiiceey也关了起来。
Did you feel a little like the world's worst prank had just been played on you?
你有没有觉得像是有人跟你开了个世界上最糟糕的玩笑？
I feel like a cheap.
我感觉自己很低贱。
You feel like a what?
你感觉什么？
Cheap. Cheap. Very cheap.
低贱。低贱。非常低贱。
Very cheap.
非常低贱。
Humiliated and very cheap.
羞辱，而且非常低贱。
Tiiceey and Afweyne, the guys who say they put the pirates out of business in Himan and Heeb, were both charged with piracy.
Tiiceey和阿夫韦内，这两个声称他们在希曼和希布消灭了海盗的家伙，都被控以海盗罪。
There's pretty strong evidence against Tiiceey. The Belgians are saying that, when Tiiceey started working with Afweyne, Afweyne was still hijacking ships and Tiiceey got wrapped up in Afweyne's criminal organization, would insert himself into the negotiations for hostage releases, and used it to run a little side hustle. He'd demand additional money from the hostages' families-- tens of thousands of dollars-- for use of the airport at Adado. That's extortion.
有相当有力的证据反对Tiiceey。比利时人说，当Tiiceey开始与阿夫韦内合作时，阿夫韦内仍在劫持船只，而Tiiceey被卷入了阿夫韦内的犯罪组织，会插手人质释放的谈判，并利用这一点搞点副业。他会向人质家庭索要额外费用——数万美元——作为使用阿达多机场的费用。那是勒索。
The Belgians claim he extorted money from the families of hostages in four specific piracy cases. One of them is the kidnapping of Rachel and Paul Chandler. That's the recording you heard at the beginning of this story. Rachel's brother, Stephen, is on the phone with Paul, telling him to trust Tiiceey.
比利时人声称他在四起具体的海盗案中从人质家庭那里勒索了钱财。其中之一就是雷切尔和保罗·钱德勒的绑架案。那就是你在故事开头听到的录音。雷切尔的哥哥斯蒂芬正在和保罗通话，告诉他信任Tiiceey。
He is a good man and you can trust him. He is not a pirate. I repeat, he is not a pirate.
他是个好人，你可以信任他。他不是海盗。我重复一遍，他不是海盗。
But Stephen told me that wasn't how he actually felt about Tiiceey in that moment. In reality--
但斯蒂芬告诉我，那并不是他当时对Tiiceey的真实感受。实际上——
I was very skeptical of him and thought he was just a greedy little thief, to be honest.
说实话，我当时对他非常怀疑，觉得他只是个贪婪的小贼。
Coming up, more of Dana Chivvis' story. We hear what actually happened between Stephen and Tiiceey-- the actual recordings of theirs conversations as they're trying to get the hostages to safety. It isn't pretty. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，更多关于达娜·奇维斯的报道。我们来听听斯蒂芬和Tiiceey之间到底发生了什么——他们试图让人质安全获释时的通话真实录音。情况并不好看。一分钟后，我们的节目从芝加哥公共广播电台继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, I Am Not a Pirate-- stories where people make that claim. Apparently it's something people say when they aren't a pirate and also when they are a pirate. We're in the middle of Dana Chivvis' story about Tiiceey, a man who returned to Somalia to try to help out and ended up accused of criminal conspiracy with pirates.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目是“我不是海盗”——人们做出这种声明的故事。显然，当一个人不是海盗时会这么说，当他们是海盗时也会这么说。我们正在达娜·奇维斯的报道中，关于Tiiceey的故事，他返回索马里试图帮忙，最终却被指控与海盗密谋犯罪。
And we pick up the story in the middle of a negotiation that Tiiceey was involved in with Stephen Collett. He was trying to arrange for safe passage for his sister and his brother-in-law, Rachel and Paul, who were being held by pirates. Again, here's Dana.
我们在Tiiceey与斯蒂芬·科莱特参与的一次谈判中继续讲述。他正在试图为他的妹妹和妹夫雷切尔和保罗安排安全通道，他们正被海盗扣押。再次有请达娜。
At this point in the negotiation, Stephen had agreed to pay the Pirates $440,000 for Rachel and Paul's release. Tiiceey wasn't involved in that part of things, but he had offered to help Stephen with the logistics of getting Rachel and Paul out of Somalia.
谈判进行到这个阶段，斯蒂芬已经同意支付给海盗44万美元以换取雷切尔和保罗的释放。Tiiceey没有参与那部分，但他主动提出帮助斯蒂芬处理将雷切尔和保罗从索马里弄出来的后勤工作。
Tiiceey wrote an email saying his administration, quote, "are not part of the pirates and don't deal or/and share money, and we are not expecting ANY--" this word is capitalized-- "ANY payment from the pirates or Paul and Rachel family. The only support we are offering was humanitarian support and to facilitate Paul and Rachel's safe passage."
Tiiceey写了一封邮件，称他的行政机构“不是海盗的一部分，不进行交易/或分享钱财，我们也不期望任何——”（这个词大写了）“任何来自海盗或保罗和雷切尔家庭的付款。我们提供的唯一支持是人道主义支持，并促进保罗和雷切尔的安全过境。”
Stephen needed permission to use the airport in Adado, which, as far as I can tell, is just a dusty landing strip a few miles outside town. As governor, Tiiceey was the only person who could give planes permission to land there, so Stephen called Tiiceey to get that permission.
斯蒂芬需要许可才能使用阿达多的机场，据我所知，那只是镇外几英里处的一条布满尘土的跑道。作为州长，Tiiceey是唯一能批准飞机在那里降落的人，所以斯蒂芬给Tiiceey打电话寻求许可。
Thank you for ringing back.
谢谢你回电。
How are you doing, sir?
你好吗，先生？
I'm fine. Did you--
我很好。你——
They talk about logistics, and then Stephen asks--
他们谈论了后勤，然后斯蒂芬问道——
How much is this going to cost us? Because we've got nothing left.
这会花多少钱？因为我们什么都没剩下了。
Listen, I'm not going to charge you anything.
听着，我不会向你收取任何费用。
That's very kind.
你太好了。
I'm not going to charge you, personally, anything-- money or anything. I'm doing this out of [INAUDIBLE]. I found out [INAUDIBLE]--
我个人不会向你收取任何钱或其他东西。我这样做是出于……我发现……
It's kind of hard to hear. Tiiceey says, "I'm not going to charge you anything as long as you pay the expenses." Four days later, when Stephen calls Tiiceey back, there's been a slight hitch in the plan.
听起来有点费劲。Tiiceey说：“只要你支付开销，我就不会向你收取任何费用。”四天后，当斯蒂芬给Tiiceey回电时，计划出了一点小偏差。
They were going to get the money to the pirates through a guy in Nairobi, but that fell through. So now they need to deliver the ransom money to the pirates at the Adado airport. Tiiceey doesn't like this.
他们本打算通过内罗毕的一个家伙把钱交给海盗，但计划失败了。所以现在他们需要把赎金送到阿达多机场交给海盗。Tiiceey不喜欢这样。
Before, the plane was just coming to pick up Rachel and Paul, but now it's also bringing a huge sack of cash, and he says that creates a big security risk. He's worried people might get violent and steal the money. He'll allow it, but he needs extra security.
之前飞机只是来接雷切尔和保罗，但现在它还要带来一大包现金，他说这造成了很大的安全风险。他担心人们可能会变得暴力并偷走钱。他会允许，但他需要额外的安全保障。
So yes, you can go ahead and bring the money to here, and we're secure almost. I arranged about 70 to 100 people-- soldiers-- in the airport area to secure the parameter and everything. And in that case, so including the fee and everything, it's going to be $21,750.
所以是的，你可以把钱带到这里，我们这里差不多是安全的。我安排了大约70到100人——士兵——在机场地区保护周边等等。在这种情况下，包括费用等等，总共是21,750美元。
Sorry, can you repeat that, please?
对不起，能重复一下吗，请？
OK. This is what I said.
好的。我是这么说的。
Tiiceey's telling Stephen that he'll arrange for about 70 to 100 soldiers to secure the airport, which will cost Stephen $21,750. Stephen wasn't expecting that.
Tiiceey在告诉斯蒂芬，他将安排大约70到100名士兵保护机场，这将花费斯蒂芬21,750美元。斯蒂芬没预料到这一点。
I-- I-- I don't know. I'm-- I'm confused about this big cost, Mohamed. You told me many times that you would not take any money. I-- I-- I know it's difficult. The family doesn't have this amount of money to spend.
我……我……我不知道。我对这笔巨额费用感到困惑，穆罕默德。你多次告诉过我你不会收任何钱。我……我知道这很难。这个家庭没有那么多钱可以花。
No.
不。
Because we've given everything to--
因为我们已经把所有东西都给了——
Listen, I'm not taking money when you want-- if you find out-- OK, this is what I'm doing. Business landing fee, the extra police, as they put it, the expenses. We are not rich like the United States or many other countries. We are a small administration. It's beyond our capacity. We have to put a lot of effort in that case.
听着，当你想要……如果你发现的话——好吧，我正在做的是。商业着陆费，额外的警察，正如他们所说的，开支。我们不像美国或其他许多国家那样富有。我们是一个小型行政机构。这超出了我们的能力。在这种情况下，我们必须付出很多努力。
I fully appreciate, but we just do not have that amount. We just do not have $20,000.
我完全理解，但我们就是没有那么多钱。我们根本没有2万美元。
So what you're telling me is you don't have it. I understand that. But how can I solve-- this is what you need, the security you need. So what should I do? Tell me. It's your call.
所以你告诉我的意思是你们没有。我理解。但我该怎么解决呢——这是你需要的，你需要的安全保障。所以我该怎么办？告诉我。这取决于你。
Depending on how you hear this call, they're either in the midst of a bureaucratic stalemate or a small-time extortion.
取决于你如何理解这个电话，他们要么处于官僚僵局中，要么处于小额勒索中。
I'm not negotiating. This is the minimum that we'll need. This is not something goes to the pocket of one person. Believe me you, I'm not-- [INAUDIBLE], I'm not getting payment whatsoever for that.
我不是在谈判。这是我们所需的最低限度。这不是进入某个人口袋的钱。相信我，我没有——我没有收到任何形式的付款。
Tiiceey is saying that the number he gave Stephen, the $21,750, that's the minimum amount needed to cover the expenses for securing the airport. He's not personally getting any of that money. They do some more haggling and then Tiiceey says, let me see what I can do. A few minutes later, he calls Stephen back. He's managed to secure a discount.
Tiiceey在说他给斯蒂芬的那个数字，21,750美元，是覆盖机场安保费用的最低金额。他个人并没有从那笔钱中得到任何好处。他们又讨价还价了一番，然后Tiiceey说，看看我能做些什么。几分钟后，他给斯蒂芬回电。他成功获得了一点折扣。
OK. This is what it is. I talked to them. The price was $21,750. And then we take 15% discount. So in that case, it's going to be $18,487.50.
好的。就是这样。我和他们谈了。价格是21,750美元。然后我们给了15%的折扣。所以总共是18,487.50美元。
Yeah. You know, we don't have this money. That's the problem. I don't have the money, and it's going to take me a long, long time to get hold of it.
是的。你知道，我们没有这笔钱。那是问题所在。我没有钱，而且我需要很长时间才能弄到。
OK. So this is what you want, Stephen? You want that airplane come with the money, no security, and then they hand out everything. That's what you want?
好的。所以这就是你想要的，斯蒂芬？你想要那架飞机带着钱来，没有安保，然后他们把一切都交出去。这就是你想要的吗？
And then the fights start in my people, and then almost 57 people die because of these small money and difficult people? Is that what you want?
然后我的人民之间就开始打斗，因为这点小钱和这些难缠的人，差不多死掉了57个人？这就是你想要的吗？
Of course I don't want anyone hurt, Mohamed. Of course I don't.
当然我不想任何人受伤，穆罕默德。当然不想。
But Stephen didn't believe that Tiiceey was worried about security. He thought it was a scam.
但斯蒂芬不相信Tiiceey是在担心安全。他认为这是一个骗局。
He knew he'd got us. He was in control. It was his airfield and he could do what he liked. We'd spoken to the local pilots, the bush pilots who do sometimes run into these places, and they said the normal fee was about $100.
他知道他抓住了我们。他在控制一切。这是他的机场，他可以随心所欲。我们和当地的飞行员谈过，那些偶尔会飞到这些地方的丛林飞行员，他们说正常费用大约是100美元。
$100 would be a normal landing fee?
100美元是正常的降落费？
Yes.
是的。
And he's asking for $21,750?
而他要价21,750美元？
That's right. Then he gave us a discount for cash.
没错。然后他还给了我们一个现金折扣。
Yeah, he did.
是的，他给了。
The UN released a report that has a lengthy section on Tiiceey and Afweyne and their alleged criminal activity. It mirrors the Belgian case closely. And in it, there's a sheet from the Himan and Heeb Regional Administration. It's signed by Tiiceey, and it outlines fees for airlines using the Adado airport.
联合国发布了一份关于Tiiceey和阿夫韦内及其涉嫌犯罪活动的详尽调查报告。报告与比利时的案件高度吻合。其中有一份希曼和希布地区行政机构的表格。上面有Tiiceey的签名，列出了航空公司使用阿达多机场的费用。
The costs are $5 per ticket, $1 per sack of outgoing goods, $50 security fee for a 50-seat flight. Of course, those prices were for normal flights in and out of Adado carrying regular passengers and bags of khat, not two British hostages and nearly half a million dollars. But still, given those prices, $21,750 seems a bit extravagant, even with the extra security.
费用是每张票5美元，每袋外运货物1美元，50座飞机安保费50美元。当然，这些价格是针对阿达多往返的正常航班，携带普通乘客和恰特草，而不是两名英国人质和近50万美元。但即便如此，鉴于这些价格，21,750美元似乎有点离谱，即便是算上额外的安保。
I went around and around with Tiiceey about this fee and what it was spent on, and it never added up. Maybe he was pocketing part of the cash. Maybe he wasn't. Maybe the people he had to pay for the use of the airport and security were inflating their price. There's no way to know for sure.
我反复和Tiiceey讨论这笔费用以及它是如何花掉的，但怎么也对不上账。也许他把部分现金揣进了自己的腰包。也许没有。也许他必须支付机场使用费和安保费的人抬高了价格。没办法确定。
Finally, Stephen gave in. They agreed on a price of $20,000. The money was transferred to a Himan and Heeb Administration account. Tiiceey assures Stephen it's not his personal account. He's not a dictator.
最终，斯蒂芬妥协了。他们以2万美元的价格达成一致。钱转到了希曼和希布行政机构的账户。Tiiceey向斯蒂芬保证这不是他的个人账户。他不是独裁者。
The ransom and rescue operation is set for June 17. The pilot will take off from Nairobi at dawn with a leather bag containing five bundles of $100 bills-- $440,000 in total. There's one last glitch, which is that the pilot refuses to actually touch down in Adado because--
赎金和救援行动定于6月17日进行。飞行员将在黎明时分从内罗毕起飞，带着一个皮革袋，里面有五捆100美元的钞票——总共44万美元。最后一个小插曲是飞行员拒绝真正降落在阿达多，因为——
Well, he didn't want to be caught by pirates.
嗯，他不想被海盗抓住。
So instead, he'll fly very low to the ground and two security guys on board will chuck the ransom out the window into the pirate's hands-- a guy called Ali. He's the pirate Stephen has been negotiating with for months. The pilot will know where Ali is because-- and I'm not joking here-- he will mark the spot with an X on the roof of his car.
所以他会飞得很低，机上的两名安保人员会把赎金从窗户扔出去，直接交给海盗——一个叫阿里的人。他就是斯蒂芬协商了几个月的海盗。飞行员会知道阿里在哪里，因为——我没开玩笑——他会用X标记在车顶上。
Now, Tiiceey had told Stephen he would supply 100 policemen to provide security at the airport. But when the pilot got into Adado's airspace, all he saw was one lonely car with an X on its roof, parked off the end of the runway. The pilot was already on the phone with Stephen, so Stephen called Tiiceey and said--
现在，Tiiceey告诉斯蒂芬他会提供100名警察在机场提供安保。但当飞行员进入阿达多空域时，他只看到了一辆孤零零的车，车顶上有个X，停在跑道尽头。飞行员当时正在和斯蒂芬通话，所以斯蒂芬打电话给Tiiceey说——
Where are your men? And suddenly, another vehicle appeared from the town. The pilot said, oh yes, I can see a pickup coming from the town now with a couple of men in the back.
你的人在哪里？突然，另一辆车从镇上出现了。飞行员说，噢，是的，我能看到一辆皮卡从镇上过来了，后面有几个人。
Oh, my god. So his 100 security men and five armored cars turned out to be a pickup truck and two guys.
噢，天哪。所以他的100名安保人员和五辆装甲车最终变成了一辆皮卡和两个家伙。
Well, a pickup truck driver and two guys in the back.
好吧，一名皮卡司机和后面两个家伙。
Who were late.
他们迟到了。
The pilot did one low pass and then on the second, they threw the ransom out the window. Ali called Stephen a few minutes later to confirm he had the money. The pirates were supposed to spend the next few hours counting it, and then once they confirmed it was all there, they would hand Rachel and Paul over.
飞行员做了一次低空通场，第二次经过时，他们把赎金从窗户扔了出去。阿里几分钟后给斯蒂芬打电话，确认他收到了钱。海盗本应花接下来的几个小时清点钱数，然后一旦确认数目正确，就会放了雷切尔和保罗。
So what happened?
那么发生了什么？
It all went quiet. And that worried us a little. We did have suspicions. Even that night we thought, this doesn't sound good. And we did try ringing Ali, but his phone was turned off that night.
一切都归于寂静。这让我们有点担心。我们确实有怀疑。甚至在那晚我们还想，这听起来不太妙。我们确实试过拨打阿里的电话，但他的电话那天晚上关机了。
He didn't hear from Ali again for two days. And then Stephen got a text demanding another $1 million in ransom. Eventually, Stephen got Ali on the phone. Ali's gone full Blackbeard and Stephen's stiff upper lip is gone. He tries threats. Ali mocks him. Here's that call.
他两天没再收到阿里的消息。然后斯蒂芬收到了一条短信，要求再付100万美元赎金。最终，斯蒂芬接通了阿里的电话。阿里的“黑胡子”本性毕露，斯蒂芬也不再硬撑了。他试图威胁。阿里嘲笑他。这是那通电话。
We will tell all the ship bosses that the Somali pirates cannot be trusted. That you-- you, Ali-- cannot be trusted. I will talk to them now and I--
我们会告诉所有的船东，索马里海盗不可信任。你——你，阿里——不可信任。我现在就会跟他们谈，我会——
Don't you know that pirates, we are all thieves? All of us are all thieves. We are all dirty people.
你难道不知道海盗吗，我们都是小偷？我们所有人都是小偷。我们都是肮脏的人。
Ali says, don't you know that pirates are all thieves? We're all dirty people. Like, come on, Stephen. What did you expect? Ali laughs at him.
阿里说：“你难道不知道海盗都是小偷吗？我们都是肮脏的人。”就像是，拜托，斯蒂芬。你期待什么？阿里嘲笑他。
You're lying, cheating scum, Ali. The shipowners will never, ever trust you again. When you're ready to talk of the release of Rachel and Paul--
你这个撒谎的、欺诈的烂人，阿里。船东们再也不会、永远不会再相信你了。当你准备好谈雷切尔和保罗的释放时——
[INAUDIBLE], Stephen--
（听不清），斯蒂芬——
--call me. You have my number. You can call me this time, between 11:00 and 12 o'clock your time. I will only talk about the release of Rachel and Paul. Bye.
——打给我。你有我的号码。你可以在这个时间打给我，在你时间11点到12点之间。我只会谈论雷切尔和保罗的释放。再见。
No, but I will talk about the money.
不，但我会谈谈钱的事。
The pirates didn't release Rachel and Paul for another five months.
海盗们又过了五个月才释放雷切尔和保罗。
Fast forward to now. The UN and the Belgians and Stephen Collett say that those phone calls, where Tiiceey is demanding money of Stephen, that's extortion. He's refusing to let Stephen use the Adado airport unless Stephen pays him an amount that far exceeds the normal cost for use of the airport. And they say this is part of a pattern with Tiiceey, that he did this in at least three other hostage cases. Up to $120,000 in one case.
快进到现在。联合国、比利时人和斯蒂芬·科莱特说，Tiiceey向斯蒂芬索要钱的那些电话是勒索。他拒绝让斯蒂芬使用阿达多机场，除非斯蒂芬支付远超正常费用的钱。他们说这是Tiiceey的一贯模式，他在至少三起其他的人质案件中也这么做过。其中一起案件高达12万美元。
Tiiceey says he's innocent of all charges of wrongdoing. But two months after we started talking, I heard all those recordings of his phone calls and I realized that some of the things he told me weren't true. For instance, we were talking about the plan for Rachel and Paul's release and he told me--
Tiiceey说他所有不当行为的指控都是清白的。但在我们开始谈话两个月后，我听了所有那些电话录音，意识到他告诉我的一些事情并非事实。例如，我们谈到了雷切尔和保罗释放计划时，他告诉我——
No. No, there's no cost whatsoever.
不。不，没有任何成本。
He says. "There's no cost whatsoever." That's not what I heard on that phone call with Stephen.
他说，“没有任何成本。”那不是我在与斯蒂芬的通话中听到的。
You're saying you didn't ask him for any money.
你是说你没向他要任何钱。
No, I never asked him for money.
没有，我从来没向他要过钱。
OK. I think-- I think we can clear this up. I want to play something for you.
好的。我想……我想我们可以澄清这一点。我想给你听点东西。
(ON TAPE) So all the fees and everything with the fee, it's going to come to $21,750.
（录音）所以所有的费用和一切杂费，加起来是21,750美元。
I played him that phone call you heard. At first, he sounded confused. He stuck with his denial.
我给他听了你刚才听到的那个电话。起初，他听起来很困惑。他坚持他的否认。
Stephen Collett, he called me, but I never asked him for money.
斯蒂芬·科莱特，他打给我，但我没向他要钱。
Well, you just-- I mean, you just heard yourself, right? Ask him for money in that tape I just played you.
嗯，你刚才……我的意思是，你自己刚才听到了，对吧？你在我刚才给你听的磁带里向他要钱。
No, I understand. I understand very clearly.
不，我理解。我非常清楚地理解。
Tiiceey told me the $21,750 was money the airport owners were demanding, not him.
Tiiceey告诉我21,750美元是机场所有者要求的费用，不是他。
But Tiiceey, I mean, you can see how this would look like extortion.
但Tiiceey，我的意思是，你可以看出这看起来像勒索。
In a way, yes, I can understand. It looks like extortion, but it wasn't extortion in reality.
在某种程度上，是的，我可以理解。它看起来像是勒索，但在现实中并不是勒索。
How is it not extortion?
怎么就不是勒索了？
We don't have that much money to pay.
我们没有那么多钱可以支付。
But explain how it's not extortion.
但解释一下为什么这不是勒索。
OK. I didn't have-- yes, to him, it's extortion. I understand. That's what I'm saying. But to me, at that time, I didn't have that much money to cover.
好的。我没有——是的，对他来说，这是勒索。我理解。我刚才就是这么说的。但对我来说，在那个时候，我没有那么多钱可以支付。
Meaning his administration couldn't cover the expenses. And the fact that no security was on duty when the pilot dropped the ransom? Tiiceey explained that when he learned the pilot wasn't going to land the plane, he decided there was no reason to send police that day. But he says he used Stephen's money five months later, when Rachel and Paul were finally released. And in a book Rachel and Paul wrote about their ordeal, they do describe driving to the airport with Tiiceey in a convoy of 15 Toyotas and three or four trucks mounted with guns.
意思是他的行政机构无法负担开支。那飞行员空投赎金时没有安保人员当班的事实怎么解释？Tiiceey解释说，当他得知飞行员不会降落飞机时，他决定那天没有理由派警察去。但他说是五个月后雷切尔和保罗终于获释时，他用了斯蒂芬的钱。在雷切尔和保罗写的一本关于他们磨难的书里，他们确实描述了与Tiiceey坐在一起，在一个由15辆丰田车和三四辆架着枪的卡车组成的车队里开车去机场。
We had to hang up before we were done talking about this. The next time I reached him was two days later.
在我们还没谈完这件事之前，我们不得不挂断了电话。我两天后再次联系他。
Let me go back a little bit. And this, I've never discussed with anyone before what I'm saying now, except to you. First, I call the airport committee and I told them that this is what's going on. This is what's going to happen.
让我回溯一点。关于我现在说的这些，我以前从未和任何人讨论过，除了你。首先，我给机场委员会打电话，告诉他们发生了什么。这就是将会发生的事情。
Tiiceey tells me he asked the owners of the airport to let Rachel and Paul use it for free as a humanitarian gesture, but they said no. They said, we built an airport. We get to charge people to use it. So then Tiiceey says he went to the regional parliament and asked them to step in. I wasn't able to confirm any of this, by the way.
Tiiceey告诉我他请求机场所有者作为人道主义姿态让雷切尔和保罗免费使用，但他们拒绝了。他们说，我们建了机场，我们就得收费。于是Tiiceey说他去找了地区议会，请求他们干预。顺便说一句，我无法证实这一点。
He says they also said no. His hands were tied. He had to ask for the $21,750. He said, actually, the airport owners weren't making much profit for themselves at that price. Regardless, $21,750 is the number he now admits he demanded from Stephen.
他说他们也拒绝了。他的手被捆住了。他不得不要求那21,750美元。他说，实际上，机场所有者以那个价格并没有赚多少利润。无论如何，21,750美元是他现在承认向斯蒂芬索要的数字。
Actually, he didn't like it.
事实上，他不乐意。
No.
不。
And Stephen, to be honest with you, I knew that, because if I were in his shoes, it's going to be saying we're all pissed off and feel betrayed, lied to me or something.
而斯蒂芬，说实话，我知道，因为如果我是他，也会觉得被激怒，觉得被背叛、被骗了什么的。
Yeah.
是的。
But I explained to him. I explained to him again and again and then--
但我向他解释了。我一遍又一遍地向他解释，然后——
But the way you explain it to him, it sounds very much as though you're telling him, I'm in charge of the airport and I talked to my committee, and we assessed that it's going to cost you this much. You don't explain it to him the way that you just explained it to me. In the way you just explained it to me, you're not responsible for any of the cost.
但你向他解释的方式，听起来非常像是你在告诉他：“我是机场的负责人，我跟我的委员会谈过了，我们评估这会花你这么多钱。”你解释的方式跟你刚才向我解释的方式不一样。以刚才向我解释的方式，你对这些费用不负责任。
But Dana, I didn't want to explain it the way I explained to you.
但达娜，我不想用我刚才向你解释的方式向他解释。
How come?
为什么？
I didn't want to show him that I was kind of weak in a way. It shows me that I was weak, and I didn't want to show that. And I'm telling you that I never discussed it with anyone before, except you now, the details.
我不想向他展示出我在某种程度上很软弱。这显示出我很软弱，我不想表现出来。我现在告诉你，除了你，我以前从未和任何人讨论过细节。
What were you worried about? Why were you worried about looking weak to Stephen?
你在担心什么？你为什么要担心在斯蒂芬面前显得软弱？
Because, what I'm saying is, if Stephen finds out that I don't have control of anything, then he will find out that I don't have control of what I'm saying. And I'm the man who says, hey, I control Himan and Heeb. In a way, yes, I controlled Himan and Heeb. I didn't lie about that. But I don't control certain areas, and there are certain elements that I have no authority whatsoever.
因为，我想说的是，如果斯蒂芬发现我无法控制任何事情，那么他就会发现我无法控制我所说的话。我是那个说“嘿，我控制希曼和希布”的人。在某种程度上，是的，我控制了希曼和希布。我没在这件事上撒谎。但我无法控制某些领域，有些领域我没有任何权威。
Tiiceey told me he was worried that if Stephen or the pirates realized he didn't have as much control over the airport as they thought he did that the deal would fall apart and Rachel and Paul would remain in captivity. So he swallowed a bitter pill and demanded the money from Stephen.
Tiiceey告诉我他很担心，如果斯蒂芬或海盗意识到他并没有像他们以为的那样控制机场，交易就会失败，雷切尔和保罗就会继续被囚禁。所以他忍气吞声，向斯蒂芬索要了钱。
I was pissed off. Yes, of course. I lost that war. But I knew I am going to win another war. I was feeling very complicated. And I was feeling very, in a way, yes, I'm doing something positive and, in a way, I was doing something horrible. And I'm the one who's delivering the message on both sides.
我感到很愤怒。是的，当然。我输了那场战争。但我知道我会赢下另一场战争。我感觉非常复杂。我感觉……在某种程度上，是的，我正在做积极的事情，而在某种程度上，我正在做可怕的事情。我是那个在双方之间传递信息的人。
He was doing something positive, helping to free Rachel and Paul. And he was doing something horrible, demanding money from Rachel's desperate brother.
他在做积极的事，帮助解救雷切尔和保罗。他也在做可怕的事，向雷切尔绝望的哥哥索要钱财。
There is a lot of things I regret-- I should do differently. But my intention was very good. I'd never be a pirate in my life. And if I did something stupid or something that some other person doesn't like, I'm sorry. But my intention was good. That's what I'm saying. And I don't know how to explain it other than that.
有很多事情我感到后悔——我本应该做得不同。但我的动机非常纯正。我一生中从未做过海盗。如果我做了什么愚蠢的事情，或者让别人不喜欢的事情，我很抱歉。但我的动机是好的。我就是想说这些。除了这个，我不知道该怎么解释。
Somali pirates were once just Somali fishermen. But then in the '90s, during the Civil War, when there was no longer government, they watched foreign boats sail into their waters, scoop up their fish, and leave unpunished. So they decided to do something about it. Initially, the fishermen just wanted to scare the illegal boats away, but then some of them started charging those boats a fine. Fines turned into ransoms, and Somali piracy was born.
索马里海盗曾经只是索马里的渔民。但在90年代内战期间，当不再有政府时，他们看着外国船只驶入他们的水域，捕捞他们的鱼，然后逍遥法外。所以他们决定对此采取行动。起初，渔民只是想把这些非法船只吓走，但后来有些人开始对这些船只收取罚款。罚款变成了赎金，索马里海盗就这样诞生了。
In a semi-lawless state like Somalia, without a functioning government, everything is up for rationalization. One man's fine is another man's ransom. Or in Tiiceey's case, one man's airport fee is another man's extortion. I think it's possible that Tiiceey sincerely believes he was doing the right thing.
在一个像索马里这样半无政府状态的国家，没有运作良好的政府，一切皆可合理化。一个人的罚款是另一个人的赎金。或者在Tiiceey的案件中，一个人的机场费是另一个人的勒索。我认为Tiiceey可能真诚地相信他做的是正确的事情。
I ran all this past a former US diplomat who worked in Somalia and has followed it closely for years. She didn't want me to use her name, but she dealt with Tiiceey when he was in Adado. And she's worked with lots of people in Somalia like Tiiceey-- people who've spent years in the US and then returned to work in Somalia. She says people like Tiiceey, who have lived outside Somalia for years, they often have a hard time when they return. She called them in-between people.
我把这些情况告诉了一位曾驻索马里、多年来一直密切关注该地区的前美国外交官。她不想让我使用她的名字，但她在阿达多时和Tiiceey打过交道。她曾与许多像Tiiceey这样在索马里的人打过交道——那些在美国度过多年后又回到索马里工作的人。她说像Tiiceey这样在索马里之外生活了多年的人，回到索马里时往往很难适应。她称他们为“中间人”。
They come of age living in the US, learn how the country runs here, and then they go back. And they can't play the US game 100%, but they also can't play the Somali game 100%, and they get in trouble. She said Tiiceey probably went to Himan and Heeb with the best of intentions, but she said, quote, "with no finances to support government functions in one of the most dangerous security situations anywhere in the world, Tiiceey and others have been drawn into that murky place, where they believe that they have no choice but to find accommodations with those who are engaged in corrupt or criminal practices. With their Western backgrounds, they can't claim that they don't understand what constitutes criminal behavior."
他们在生活在美国期间成年，学会了这里的运作方式，然后他们回去了。他们无法100%按美国的规则行事，但也无法100%按索马里的规则行事，于是他们陷入了麻烦。她说Tiiceey可能带着最好的意图去了希曼和希布，但她说，“由于没有任何财政支持政府职能，又处于世界上最危险的安全局势之一，Tiiceey和其他人被卷入了那个浑水之中，他们认为除了与那些从事腐败或犯罪活动的人达成妥协外，别无选择。由于他们的西方背景，他们无法声称自己不知道什么是犯罪行为。”
She told me Tiiceey meddled in too many things he should have stayed out of. And he wasn't savvy enough to protect himself, to add layers of deniability, have someone else handle those phone negotiations, put some distance between himself and the criminals. Not that she was advocating these things for him or anyone else. And she wanted me to make clear that she does not condone piracy. But that was her theory.
她告诉我Tiiceey插手了太多他不该插手的事情。他不够精明来保护自己，不能增加拒绝的层次，没让别人处理那些电话谈判，没与罪犯保持距离。并不是说她在为他或任何人辩护。她想让我明确一点，她并不宽恕海盗行为。但这是她的理论。
I put this to Tiiceey. He agreed that he should have protected himself better.
我把这些传达给了Tiiceey。他同意他本应更好地保护自己。
That is what, basically, the moral of what happened to me. So I learned my lesson, which is you have to protect yourself, whatever it takes.
这就是我身上发生的事情的教训。所以我学到了教训，那就是无论付出什么代价，你必须保护自己。
Do you think you were a little naive?
你觉得你当时有点天真吗？
Yes, I was. That's what I said, right? I said I was naive. I got carried away because I didn't think about the consequences. I thought we are in perfect world-- that everybody was helping. So that's why, yeah, I was naive.
是的，我是。正如我所说，对吧？我说过我很天真。我当时被冲昏了头脑，因为我没考虑后果。我以为我们生活在一个完美的世界里——每个人都在帮忙。所以，是的，我确实很天真。
Tiiceey's case is on appeal right now. The piracy charges were dropped for lack of evidence, but he was convicted of being involved in a criminal organization of pirates. If he loses the appeal, he could spend the next six years in prison. If he wins, he could get out in June. Once he's out, he says he'll go back to Minneapolis, take a pause, be with his kids. But after that, he might return to Somalia and run for president.
Tiiceey的案子目前正在上诉中。海盗罪因证据不足已被撤销，但他被判参与海盗犯罪组织。如果他输了上诉，他可能要在监狱里度过接下来的六年。如果他赢了，他可能在六月就能出来。他说一旦出来，他会回到明尼阿波利斯，休息一下，陪陪孩子。但那之后，他可能会回到索马里竞选总统。
Dana Chivvis. She works on our program and on the Serial podcast.
达娜·奇维斯。她在我们节目和Serial播客工作。
Act Two, C.E.Yo-Ho-Ho.
第二幕：海盗公司的CEO。
So today, we've heard two stories about how, when you get close to pirates, people start thinking that you're one of them. That you're living by pirate rules. And so we thought we would close today's program with this story of somebody who got involved with pirates and then went on to remake the rules. Remake the rules of piracy. Here's Stephanie Foo.
所以今天，我们听到了两个故事，讲述了当你接近海盗时，人们会开始认为你是他们的一员。你过着海盗规则的生活。所以我们想以这个故事来结束今天的节目：关于一个涉及海盗的人，然后继续重新制定规则。重写海盗的规则。这里是斯蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo）。
So here's a fact I learned recently that I love. The most powerful pirate of all time was a woman. Her name was Cheng I Sao
这是一个我最近学到的、我非常喜欢的事实。历史上最强大的海盗是一位女性。她的名字叫郑一嫂（Cheng I Sao）。
She makes the other pirates look like amateurs.
她让其他海盗看起来像业余爱好者。
She makes Blackbeard look like an amateur?
她让“黑胡子”看起来像业余爱好者？
Absolutely. She had way more money. She had a bigger fleet. She pirated for longer. And she was more successful.
绝对。她有更多的钱。她有更大的舰队。她当海盗的时间更长。而且她更成功。
That's Laura Sook Duncombe, who wrote about Cheng I Sao in her book, Pirate Women, the Princesses, Prostitutes and Privateers Who Ruled the Seven Seas.
那是劳拉·苏克·邓科姆（Laura Sook Duncombe），她在她的书《海盗女性：统治七大洋的公主、妓女和私掠船长》中写到了郑一嫂。
Cheng I Sao was Chinese. She was working on a floating brothel in the early 1800s when a pirate, Cheng I, proposed marriage to her. We don't know much about their love story, so this is a bit of legend. But supposedly, at first Cheng I Sao turned him down and tried to claw his eyes out. Then after some thought, she agreed that she would marry him but only if he would give her half of his fleet and his treasure. And he went along with it.
郑一嫂是中国人。19世纪初，她在一家水上妓院工作时，一名海盗郑一向她求婚。我们对他们的爱情故事了解不多，所以这多少带点传奇色彩。但据称，起初郑一嫂拒绝了他，还试图抓花他的眼睛。后来思考了一番，她同意嫁给他，但条件是他必须给她一半的舰队和财富。他同意了。
Cheng I Sao's husband was a pretty big deal already. But once they got married, the two of them got to work uniting warring pirate factions into one pirate monopoly. When her husband died, Cheng I Sao took over as leader of the pirate empire and grew it to the largest pirate fleet in history, which some members of our staff have insisted I mention is, apparently, a very Khaleesi move. I don't know. I don't watch Game of Thrones.
郑一嫂的丈夫当时已经相当了不起。但结婚后，两人联手将交战的海盗派系统一成一个海盗垄断集团。丈夫去世后，郑一嫂接管了海盗帝国，并将其发展成为历史上最大的海盗舰队，我们的工作人员坚持让我提到，这显然是一个非常“龙妈”（Khaleesi）式的举动。我不知道。我不看《权力的游戏》。
Anyway, Blackbeard had maybe four ships worth of pirates. But Cheng I Sao?
总之，“黑胡子”可能只有四艘海盗船。但郑一嫂呢？
Anywhere from 50,000 to 70,000 pirates with around 2,000 ships, all told.
总共有5万到7万名海盗，约2,000艘船。
Wow.
哇。
So this is larger than many legitimate navies of the time period, certainly the Chinese Navy.
这比当时许多合法的海军都要大，肯定比当时的中国海军要大。
In just one year-- 1808-- they destroyed half of the Chinese Navy's entire fleet, 63 out of 135 ships. Having 70,000 employees, that's as big as Exxon-Mobil. So Cheng I Sao ran it like a corporation. She had offices onshore, where she managed her accounts.
仅仅一年——1808年——他们就摧毁了中国海军整个舰队的一半，135艘船中摧毁了63艘。拥有7万名员工，这规模和埃克森美孚一样大。所以郑一嫂像管理公司一样管理着它。她在岸上有办事处，在那里管理她的账目。
And she came up with a whole new way of making tons of money-- a protection racket, where salt ships and rich coastal cities paid regular taxes to the pirates. If you didn't pay, you got pillaged. It was like the seafaring mafia.
而且她想出了一种赚大钱的全新方法——敲诈保护费，盐船和富裕的沿海城市要定期向海盗纳税。如果你不付钱，你就会被洗劫。这就像是海上的黑手党。
And were other pirates not doing that?
那是其他海盗没做过的吗？
That was really kind of a Cheng I Sao innovation. One of her many.
那确实算是郑一嫂的一种创新。她众多创新中的一种。
How old was she when she was doing all of this?
她做这些的时候多大？
So she was 32 when she took command.
她掌权时是32岁。
I don't know what I'm doing with my life.
我不知道我这辈子在干什么。
Another innovation of Cheng I Sao-- the rules on her ships. We know about these from a book written at the time, in 1830. Most captains had rules on their ships, of course, but her punishments were particularly extreme. For instance, rule number one, don't go AWOL.
郑一嫂的另一个创新——她船上的规则。我们通过1830年当时写的一本书了解这些。当然，大多数船长船上都有规则，但她的惩罚特别极端。例如，规则第一条，不准开小差。
So if anyone goes onshore without Cheng I Sao's permission, they get their ears slit. If they do it again, they're suffered death. They're killed.
所以如果有谁在没有郑一嫂许可的情况下上岸，就会被割掉耳朵。如果再犯，就要被处死。他们会被杀掉。
Rule number two, don't steal company treasure. Each crew could keep 20% of the booty it plundered. The rest went into the company treasure hold. And the punishment for taking more? Again, death.
规则第二条，不准偷盗公司财产。每组船员可以保留劫掠所得的20%。其余的进入公司金库。拿走更多的惩罚是什么？还是死。
There's a pretty consistent theme here. Lots of death. You disobey Cheng I Sao, death is in your future.
这里有个非常一致的主题。大量的死亡。你敢反抗郑一嫂，死亡就在等着你。
But the most famous rule in her employee handbook is the one Laura thinks no other pirate had. They could not rape their female captives. The punishment?
但她员工手册中最著名的一条是劳拉认为没有其他海盗有的规则。他们不得强奸女性俘虏。惩罚是什么？
You guessed it-- death. Immediate death.
你猜对了——死。立即处死。
Cheng I Sao ran this operation solo for three years. She evaded Chinese authorities until finally China had lost so much money and so much control of its waters that they resorted to something they really hated doing. They asked other countries for help. England and Portugal loaned the Chinese government ships. And with these ships, they come after her and trap her in a bay.
郑一嫂独自运作这个行动三年。她逃避了中国政府，直到中国最终损失了太多的金钱和太多的海域控制权，以至于他们不得不诉诸于他们非常厌恶的事情。他们请求其他国家帮助。英国和葡萄牙借给了中国政府船只。有了这些船，他们追捕她并将她困在一个海湾里。
They finally have her where they want her. So they have her surrounded. People from all over China-- government officials are coming to witness the end of this great pirate. There's no way she's getting out of this, and they're, you know, setting up lawn chairs on the deck, basically, to watch her defeat.
他们终于把她围住了。来自中国各地的政府官员都来看这位伟大海盗的终结。她不可能逃脱了，所以他们基本上在甲板上摆好折叠椅来看她失败。
They fire on her for eight days, but they can't sink her. Finally, they send out fireboats-- flaming boats full of explosives-- to her fleet. But then the wind changes. The fireboats come right back towards the government ships and damage them instead. Cheng I Sao gets away.
他们向她开火了八天，但就是打不沉她。最后，他们派出了火船——载满炸药的燃烧船——冲向她的舰队。但接着风向变了。火船径直冲回了政府船只，反而损伤了它们。郑一嫂逃走了。
But she decided she couldn't keep this up forever, so she went to Chinese leaders to negotiate a surrender. She docked her ship and walked directly into the governor general's headquarters onshore.
但她决定不能永远这样下去，所以她去和中国领导人商谈投降。她停泊了船只，径直走进了岸上总督的总部。
They're expecting pirate queen armed to the teeth with a full complement of burly bodyguards. She's this terrifying figure. And in walks this 35-year-old woman with some wives and some children, and it must have taken them completely by surprise. And I think it gave her the upper hand in the negotiations.
他们预想的是一位全副武装、带着一群彪形大汉保镖的海盗女王。她是这样一个令人恐惧的人物。结果走进来的是一个带着一些妻子和孩子的35岁女性，这肯定让他们大吃一惊。我认为这使她在谈判中占了上风。
And she got an incredible deal that amounted to basically a retirement package for her and her employees. She got to keep her plunder. She secured pardons for almost all of her pirates. But she also secured government payouts for her and her pirates to transition into civilian life and spots for some of them in the Chinese Navy. As part of this, Cheng I Sao wrote a letter of surrender to the Chinese government. Laura read part of it for me.
她获得了一份惊人的协议，基本上相当于她和她员工的退休金计划。她得以保留劫掠所得。她为几乎所有的海盗获得了赦免。但她也为她和她的海盗们争取到了政府的酬金，以过渡到平民生活，并为其中一些人在中国海军中安排了职位。作为一部分，郑一嫂写了一封投降信给中国政府。劳拉为我读了其中一部分。
"Originally, we were good people, but we became pirates for a variety of reasons. Because some of us were not careful in making friends, we fell into a bad situation and became robbers. Others of us were unable to secure a livelihood or were captured and forced into piracy. Therefore, we violated the laws of the empire and destroyed the merchants. This was unavoidable."
“起初，我们是好人，但因为各种原因我们成了海盗。因为我们中有一些人交友不慎，陷入了糟糕的境地，变成了强盗。我们中的其他人无法维持生计，或者被俘虏并被迫从事海盗行当。因此，我们违反了帝国法律，摧毁了商人的船只。这是不可避免的。”
I love how the-- I love, "this was unavoidable."
我喜欢那个——我喜欢，“这是不可避免的。”
Yeah. I would say it's almost sarcastic because it's clear she holds all the power and she does not need to do this.
是的。我会说这几乎是讽刺的，因为它很清楚她掌握着所有的权力，她根本没必要这样做。
Laura says wherever there was piracy, there were women pirates. They span hundreds of years, across the globe. It was an unusually progressive workplace, you know, for the time.
劳拉说无论哪里有海盗，哪里就有女性海盗。她们跨越了数百年，遍布全球。那是一个非常进步的工作场所，你知道，在那个时代。
That's a funny thing about piracy. You're not going to see-- a woman could not expect to rise to the ranks where they were competing with men and commanding men in most legitimate societies. And yet we see it over and over again in piracy that these women just excelled.
关于海盗，有一件有趣的事。在大多数合法的社会中，你不会看到——女性不可能期望晋升到与男性竞争并指挥男性的行列。然而，我们在海盗中一次又一次地看到这些女性脱颖而出。
I like to think that the stakes were a little bit higher, if they had to go back on land, to be gentle ladies, sitting in parlors or doing whatever work was available to women of these time periods. They knew what was in store for them if they were unsuccessful, and so I think it just made them fight harder, work harder.
我想，如果她们必须回到陆地，做温柔的淑女，坐在客厅里，或者做当时女性能做的工作，赌注可能会更高。她们知道如果不成功会面临什么，所以我认为这只是让她们战斗得更努力，工作得更努力。
That sounds very familiar.
听起来很熟悉。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program.
斯蒂芬妮·福是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "THE PIRATE SHANTY" BY WORLDWIDE ADVENTURERS]
[音乐 - 全球冒险家演唱的“海盗船歌”]
Our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo. Our staff includes Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Seth Lind, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Senior producer for our show is Brian Reed.
我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·福制作。我们的工作人员包括埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、赛斯·林德、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们节目的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Mark Hanna, the historian that you heard at the top of the program, is the author of Pirate Nests and the Rise of the British Empire, 1570 to 1740. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
马克·汉纳，你在节目开头听到的那位历史学家，是《海盗窝与大英帝国的崛起，1570-1740》一书的作者。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易中心传送给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he tells me all the time producers from the radio show keep calling him, calling him, always with the same message.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，他一直告诉我电台节目的制片人一直在给他打电话，不断地打，带着同样的消息。
We cannot work for this guy.
我们没法在这个家伙手下干活。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。